c'est mine de rien assez compliqué c'est
se battre en permanence pour l'égalité
hommes femmes dans tous les domaines en
arriver à l'égalité
c'était souhaité par tout le monde il ya
toujours des machos à la con et qu'en
tant que l'éveil des consciences se
fasse je pense que c'est ce qui est en
train de se passer
être une femme en 2018 c'est être sûr de
soi c'est peut-être libéré active être
sûr de ses compétences c'est d'être
déterminé dans ses choix
les goûts dans sa joie de vivre se dire
j'ai fait des études pour je suis
capable
givet tête haute
à part ma mère qui est juste une femme
exceptionnelle moi j'ai été biberonné à
simone de beauvoir j'ai évidemment été
fasciné par simone veil
michelle obama indépendante intelligente
déterminé mais elles sont sans doute
tout du talent un charme fou tout ce que
vous voulez mais ouais facto dans votre
liste c'est le fath au modèle en tant
que femme
[Musique]
simone veil c'est d'abord un combat
c'est une femme qui a jamais baissé les
bras
affrontez une assemblée d'hommes
benalouane important toute son oeuvre
pour moi c'est la femme du siècle c'est
un combat magnifique
j'ai serré de voir un peu de titiller
les hommes pour voir comment ils
réagiraient mieux ressentir ce que peut
vivre une femme au quotidien je mesurer
à quel point les hommes sont lourds dans
les transports en commun ya maintenant
fameux compétentes mois déjà spg valérie
bénaïm médaille pour hull a présenté
elle est intelligente pétillant fine
qu'elle est super doué dans l'animation
banque valérie benaïm parce que pour moi
c'est la filiation logique le taux proue
du début devenait peut-être dire
alessandra sublet ça ils sont rassurés
la loi gala fun jeunes
week end du 8 vous pouvez le faire ce
que j'aime les couleurs j'aime le fait
qu' on retrousse les manches on est
capable on est aussi fort que les hommes
donc si tu menais encore une fois que je
suis charmante goethe arrache les
couilles
et bien voilà bravo mesdames la lutte
continue et je suis avec vous ont pris
la photo d'une femme pulpeuse qui est
magnifique sur les jeunes adolescentes
la société leur dicte des diktats de
beauté dont soyez comme vous êtes vous
êtes magnifique quel que soit votre
morphologie quel que soit votre poids
que soit votre couleur de pour découper
cette moustache et augmenter votre
salaire ça relève d'une sorte
d'inconscient collectif à compétences
égales
j'estime qu'on doit être payé moi quand
je serai grande j'aurai un salaire
d'hommes
il faut que la parité ce soit aussi dans
les faits dans les actes ça rigole ouais
femme des années 80 mais femme jusqu'au
bout les sages ayant réussi l'amalgamé
de l'autorité du chef à être une femme
etc